that's france taiwan nigeria welcome to
the world of geo guessing new zealand
the iceland maybe ghana here is my best
guess where players guess where they are
on a google map based on one screenshot
yeah competitive google maps is the way
i like to say it wired talk to geo
guester trevor rainbolt if you look at
this possum guard those are distinct
tasmania in australia there's an eastern
road in north macedonia where there's
dead flies on the camera to find out how
he guesses countries in 0.1 seconds oh
my god
honestly i dedicated any amounts of free
time in the past 13 months to google
maps and learning countries so
here we are
first we have to see is what trevor
doing legit so we put them to the test
immediately we're going to be in latin
america we have short plates we have
white on the bottom if i could see the
crop here it would maybe be more helpful
but i do think with the white paint pull
bottoms in spanish with short plates i
would probably guess guatemala assuming
you cut off the car
i like to call these guests vibe guesses
more than anything because it is just so
intuition-based so that's using things
like road line recognition vegetation
how tropical it looks what the road is
made out of what concrete is it using
asphalt how is the roads quality even
picking up on things like what google
coverage they're using like what year
was this country covered in so all these
are going into like a calculated guess
in every single guess
now let's look at some tips and tricks
for geoguessr the first thing i always
tell people to learn is telephone poles
bollards learning what side the road
countries drive on is extremely
important
there's a couple of things that we're
looking for on utility poles do
telephone poles you're looking at what
it's made of the design if there's
stickers on it or different types of
markings on the poles because all these
different things together are very
helpful in going into an educated guess
there's different types of poles there's
ladder pulls there's holy poles there's
a-frame pulls there's hook pulls and
then from there you have like okay this
is wooden this is concrete 95 of the
poles their concrete in australia are in
victoria so if i see a concrete pole i
know i'm in victoria if i see a black
sticker driving left with looking very
tropical it's going to be mainly
malaysia or a blue sticker is in france
on their telephone poles and ladder
poles are in spain portugal france it's
very very helpful to learn these
different types of poles and what
different material each country uses on
their telephone poles to help narrow
down your guess
ballards are pretty much as road
markings in different countries every
country for the most part has a distinct
bollard so pretty much if you see one
baller you know you're going to be in
that country there's a website called
geohints.com too that has like all the
ballers listed out that's like extremely
helpful like denmark that has a yellow
top or you can go into more region
guessing based off like canada well
alberta has black white black white
bollards or australia and turkey have
similar bollards where it's like white
with a red strip or new zealand has
white with a red strip but the red strip
goes from end to end
license plates are extremely helpful as
well it's worth mentioning all license
plates are blurred so you have to learn
what blurred license plates look like a
lot of times it's easier when it's like
a very distinct color like yellow where
if it's yellow front and back it's gonna
be netherlands or luxembourg if it's
yellow just back it's gonna be the uk or
sometimes france even the length of a
license plate is a clue mexico has short
colorful plates where ecuador has short
and long plates and then there's brazil
that only has long plates
some spots are easily recognizable
because of unique characteristics
sometimes it's the shape of the sign the
hokkaido arrow sign where it's pointing
at the road line it's only really found
in where it snows really heavily in
japan which is mainly in the north and
sometimes it's really just knowing about
the google map car
north kyrgyzstan and south korea's team
were covered by different people to
where one the south was shorter so the
reflection of the camera on the mirror
was at a different angle so you would
learn what percent of the road you could
see on the mirror so you could tell
you're in south carolina versus north
and if you've seen trevor's tick tocks
you know he's able to guess the location
by literally just the soil soil guessing
really goes into every single gas but
basically what you're looking at is
you're looking at the color of the soil
and overall the vegetation that's within
the soil and around it as well is there
more pebbles is there more grass is it
more green and then overall it a lot of
it really is as much as i probably
really couldn't describe it but like
some things just look like south chile
soil okay round one here we have light
gray soil very air to climate i'm gonna
go north botswana here
slightly more east but was northbots and
once you have all that information it's
time to pinpoint so when you're
pinpointing you're looking at things the
first thing always when you're
pinpointing is to look down at the road
and see what direction the road is going
so you can get the exact angle that the
road is and then you can use that to
reference the road angle on the map so i
need to find something that lines up
with a north this angle with a curve
going west obviously using signage is
super helpful you know if there's
obviously a town name or a certain name
or a highway number you're going to use
that to pinpoint the the roads from
there some countries are a lot easier
and have a lot easier numbering than
others like for example denmark is a
very easy to pinpoint because every road
in denmark is like labeled everywhere
it's like one of the easiest
pinpointable countries because there's
just road numbers and towns everywhere
now let's see how trevor guesses in 0.1
seconds
so sweden here is a very easy guess to
most pro players mainly because really
where you only get those short white
dashed key outer lines is estonia and
sweden but mainly very very common in
sweden norway has dashed out realized as
well but they're longer in length what
was that france
oh my god so the ballers we had in the
bottom right there it's black and white
but if it was colored it would be white
red white and it's like a lot bigger
round baller than most usual bollards
and those are only really found in
scotland and france but with driving
right there we would have to be in
france even with all these tips there
are some places that are still really
really challenging baltic roulette is
the depth of a lot of world records so
the baltics are so hard because they all
look the same the most that i struggle
with are indonesia and russia because
they're humongous fun facts if you take
indonesia and stretch it to actual size
it's actually bigger than the united
states i don't think i've ever 5k to
russia lock now that i remember it or
indonesia all right one day one day i'm
still getting things wrong i'm still
getting reasons wrong so there's more to
learn right now i'm learning australia
just because i want to be more precise
at learning australia and then
eventually i'll probably give it to
russia i would say after russia is
turkey i really want to bear turkey
that's the best part about this game is
as much as the best player in the world
is at this game he has so much to learn
especially as google updates coverage we
get more countries recently india got
released which we've never had india
coverage before so now we have to learn
india i love nothing more than the
gesture community we're all just a bunch
of nerds that sit in discord and search
through locations and find different
commonalities and countries and play
together and compete together there's
probably 500 of us competing at a high
level that's growing every day we've
done this forever for years for just
ourselves and so forth to finally have a
platform where other people are actually
learning about us and we have eyes on
what we've spent so many hours just for
an urge to learn about the world